it's a bleak picture this year alone has
seen storms
floods and wildfires
now according to scientists it is
unequivocal that humans are largely to
blame for warming the oceans
land and sea through our burning of coal
oil and gas
you've been telling us for over three
decades of the dangers of allowing the
planets
warm the world listened but didn't hear
the world listened but it did not act
strongly enough
and as a result climate change is a
problem
that is here now nobody is safe
and it's getting worse faster the first
un report issued in 1990
had predicted human-caused climate
change would become evident
at the time it couldn't prove with
evidence that it was happening
that's now changed on nearly every
measurement
our climate is more extreme and is said
to get worse
human activities are causing climate
change and making extreme weather events
more
frequent and severe second
it shows that climate change is
affecting every region on our planet
and lastly it explains that strong rapid
sustained reductions in carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gas emissions
would be required to limit global
warming
right now it's some of the world's
poorest countries that are feeling the
effects
but they contribute less to greenhouse
gases
there is hope though if the biggest
emitters are able to commit to and
deliver sharp reductions in greenhouse
gas emissions
we may see some positive changes
but it would happen within the next 20
years
the culvert 19 pandemic briefly reduced
air pollution
but it did not hold climate change the
damage it seems is already
done some issues like greenland's
glaciers melting and sea levels rising
are irreversible
and unless there's dramatic change in
human behavior
the world should expect an unsettled and
uncertain future
assad big al jazeera
let's get some analysis now we can hear
from tom burke who's from the
think tank uh e3g so tom thanks for
joining us here today
the world is clearly in trouble the un
climate summit
in glasgow is coming up what needs to
happen
now at the policy level
well the most important message from
this report is that we've got to stop
burning fossil fuels as fast as we can
and that means that the summit meeting
in glasgow
is a really important moment for the
world to come together
and start doing more than it's already
been doing
to make that happen and i suppose there
are three things that have really got to
come out
we've got to uh first of all
move forward the 100 billion dollars
that were promised to help the
emerging countries play their part and
we've not done that
the second thing that's got to come out
is we've got to have
commitments from countries to reduce uh
greenhouse gas emissions by about nine
uh gigatons of carbon uh
right away so that we've got any chance
of keeping the
uh temperature below 1.5 and then we've
really
got to agree to put an end to the use of
coal
in our energy systems
but the thing is tom we've said this
countless times haven't we
all these things have got to happen and
this is what needs to take place
but it never does why is this time going
to be any different
in what way will this report add heft to
those negotiations
in glasgow can it really make a
difference
well what i think has really happened
and the events you've just been
describing
make it very clear that what the things
that are happening in people's lives
are validating the science
experientially for them
i think that will matter politically but
at the end of the day
this really is a problem for politicians
to solve
we have the technology we know we can
afford to do this
it's really a question of politicians uh
recognizing how urgent and immediate
this problem is
and actually doing the things we already
know we need to do
in order to solve it now why will this
time be different
i honestly don't know that it will it
really depends on how our politicians
react
to the kind of pictures you've been
showing
you say we have the technology but
really do we
do we have the ability to to make that
giant
energy transition that is needed but as
soon as 2050 that's less than 30
years we're just not ready for that are
we
uh well again technologically
it's no i mean given the kind of
technology little means
we have today and the way the globe can
it's not bigger than it was
than the exercise involved in the united
states
uh after pearl harbor in turning their
economy over from producing cars
to producing tanks in less than a year
we're much more technically competent
and indeed economically competent than
we were then the u.s was able to do it
then
the world is technically capable of
doing it now
but it really is a question whether we
can find the right kind of political
agreements
to do that but i don't think that that
we know the technologies we need to do
to replace
fossil fuels we know they're there we're
not investing them
enough in them at scale in order to meet
the deadlines we need to meet
great to get your thoughts tom
appreciate that that's tom burke from
the think tank
e3g